E aí
e o que você faz com seus privilégios
essa pergunta eu me fiz as seis anos
atrás na época eu tinha o privilégio de
dar aula no colégio particular de Elite
Não Ter iniciado a minha transição de
gênero e me sobrar no final do mês cerca
de 300 reais eu poderia juntar esses
privilégios e no final do ano nas férias
fazer uma viagem mas não era isso que me
motivava nós professores e professores
temos a alma que xô Teka e sonhamos em
usar educação para transformar
realidades
Então não temos privilégios aluguei uma
sala e Montei um curso gratuito de
educação popular para um dos grupos mais
vulneráveis que há no Brasil e na
América Latina que são as pessoas
travestis e transexuais
eu não sei se vocês sabem mas
infelizmente noventa porcento das
travestis e transexuais do país estão na
prostituição em Belo Horizonte 91 por
cento das travestis transexuais não
concluíram o ensino médio Seis por cento
foi expulsa de casa com menos de 13 anos
de idade e nossa expectativa de vida
estima-se não supera 35 anos nós
travestis e transexuais ainda não
estamos hoje por nome banheiro
identidade Sim a nossa falta é para que
respeita o nosso nome social
respeita a nossa identidade para que
podemos ter acesso ao banheiro
é porque Infelizmente o STF Superior
Tribunal Federal está há quase dez anos
discutindo com o banheiro eu vou usar
nós lutamos por nome banheiro identidade
É porque eu tiro no mínimo para
reconhecer nossos corpos como corpos
humanos ainda não foi dado não foi
conquistado
Olá neste projeto pedagógico idealizei
eu queria a primeira casa de acolhimento
de travestis e transexuais em situação
de rua de Belo Horizonte e a cada tijolo
que eu colocava nesse projeto social era
um tijolo que eu colocava na minha
coragem de iniciar minha transição de
gênero
e eu fiz a minha transição de gênero no
momento que o Brasil vivia a sua maior
crise econômica desde
1929 naquele momento eu vi que se eu
queria transformações profundas na
sociedade eu precisava acreditar na
política e mais do que isso precisava
ocupar a política
e então me filho é um partido e é uma
frase do Apocalipse que eu adoro que diz
que Deus vomitara os mornos
sim não há coisa pior que uma pessoa
morna uma vida morna nós temos que ser
intensas em tudo e eu vivi intensamente
aquele partido EA depois de um ano ele
me convidou para disputar o governo do
estado de Minas Gerais Eu recusei me
convida para disputar para Deputado
Estadual e Federal também rejeitei E aí
me convidaram pode ficar com a Senadora
da República E aceitei por entender que
no contexto de crise econômica o sistema
capitalista tende a nos reduzir a coisa
máquina e objeto que só trabalha só
produz
para enfrentar essa realidade então é
necessário Não só de escutar o concreto
mas também o simbólico o simbólico é
tudo aquilo que não é concreto Olá tudo
que não é material e tudo que nos
humaniza eram simbólico e moro sonhos a
fé a paixão as utopias a esperança é no
simbólico e mora Dom Quixote e a palavra
Senado em sua etimologia significa
senhores é um espaço para senhores a
casa dos Senhores
tanto é que o primeiro banheiro feminino
construído no senado foi só em 2016
então uma travesti querer penetrar os
passos dos Senhores ser extremamente
simbólico
quando a não sei a minha campanha
dizendo que eu era a primeira transexual
do Brasil a disputar o cabo o senador da
República as minhas redes sociais foram
atacadas por milhares de mensagens de
ódio e a palavra que mais aparecia era
nojo
e o que é isso que parte da sua cidade
tem em relação a nossa travestis e
transexuais em
eu fiz a campanha sem nenhuma estrutura
sem nenhum dinheiro
sabia que a chance de Vitória mínima mas
não importa não importava eu não tava
disputando votos que agora disputando
consciências até porque nossos sonhos
não cabem nas urnas
eu perdi a eleição mas conquistei mais
de 351 mil votos para que me colocou uma
quarta mulher mais votada da história
das eleições em Minas Gerais e fui
votada nos 853 municípios de Minas
Gerais E aí você me pergunta Duda essa
foi sua maior vitória eu digo que não a
minha maior vitória é saber que por onde
eu passo por menor que seja cidade
sempre que uma pessoa que me diz Duda
meu pai não me aceita não mas diz que
voltei você e eu respondo seu pai te
aceito assim e eu tinha dificuldade para
aceitar os próprios preconceitos e seu
pai não votou em mim não votou nele
mesmo dizendo que a partir daquele dia
ele se olhar diversidade de outra forma
e essa é a maior vitória saber que
351 mil pessoas em Minas Gerais teve um
avanço de consciência e
nessa eleição de 2018 a minha
companheira engravidou e dessa gravidez
nasceu minha filha sol e depois de Muita
batalha eu conquistei o direito à
licença-maternidade
até onde sei foi a primeira mulher
transexual do país a efetivar e
conquistar pelo INSS os quatro meses de
direito à licença-maternidade
no ano passado eclodiu a pandemia da
covid-19 e aprofundou se a crise
econômica no Brasil eu entendi então que
não bastava Hospital simbólico mas era
também necessário disputar o concreto
então não sei minha candidatura a
vereadora por Belo Horizonte
optei por fazer uma campanha Lixo Zero
sempre me nenhum santinho nem um
panfleto nenhuma Bandeira
e até porque segundo o Tribunal Superior
Eleitoral a quantidade deste impresso
gerado da campanha 2016 da letra
produzir 40 milhões de livros e aí eu te
pergunto você prefere 40 milhões de
livros ou Aquela quantidade de lixo
eleitoral jogada pela cidade e segundo o
próprio Tribunal Superior Eleitoral em
2016 foram cortadas cerca de 600 mil
árvores para produzir material de
campanha por isso além de não imprime
nenhum material Eu também optei E fiz
uma promessa de campanha Dizendo Que
cada voto que eu tivesse seria uma
árvore que plantar ia Eu terminei as
eleições com quase 40 mil votos fato me
colocou com uma pessoa mais votada da
história de Belo Horizonte e a primeira
transexual Eleita da Capital Mineira
após ganhar as eleições eu recebi duas
ameaças de morte do maior grupo de hoje
da internet do qual surgiram aqueles
terroristas que cometeram o atentado na
escola de Suzano em São Paulo
e os e-mails que recebi diziam que iriam
me matar e transformar a escolhe que eu
trabalhava no mar de sangue esses
e-mails também foram encaminhados para a
direção da escola e para os donos da
escola alertando que se eu continuasse
dando aula ali aquela escola iria virar
um mar de sangue queriam forçar minha
demissão e eu fui demitida
e
após ser demitida
receber milhares de mensagens de ódio
a ETEC andar com seguranças
e para manter viva você me pergunta se
eu faria tudo isso de novo eu respondo
que sim e não me arrependo de nada
porque se for necessário eu dar um passo
atrás para que o grupo do qual faço
parte de três passos para frente farei
sempre porque a pergunta que me move e
que sempre moveu Ué o que você faz com
seus privilégios